Precisamente en cuanto a la batería de
misiles se le preguntó a los mandatarios
si tenían escalación y escalamiento del
conflicto después de que Estados Unidos
le diera estos misiles a Ucrania el
presidente dijo que no que esto no era
motivo para escalar el conflicto
precisamente porque eran eran misiles
que estaban destinados a la defensa
aérea la defensa del territorio y no a
escalar el conflicto por su parte dijo
que estaban muy abiertos a recibir aún
más misiles para defender aún más el
territorio ucraniano biden resaltó que
Estados Unidos le ha dado más de 20 mil
millones de dólares en ayuda militar a
Ucrania desde que empezó esta invasión
rusa territorio ucraniano y pues dijo
además que Estados Unidos acudió a más
de 220.000 inmigrantes ucranianos en lo
que va de esta guerra que son cerca de
diez meses y Cristóbal como avanzábamos
el siguiente punto de la agenda de
zelenski es su discurso ante el congreso
estadounidense que se espera de este
discurso Y por qué es clave para el
presidente ucraniano
es clave porque precisamente en la rueda
de prensa dijo que a pesar de los
cambios que se presentan y que se van a
presentar el 3 de enero cuando los
republicanos tomen la mayoría en la
cámara de representantes pues espera
apoyo y partidista tanto demócratas como
republicanos Precisamente en aprobar
este presupuesto militar de ayuda
Ucrania para el 2023 que es de cerca de
45,000 millones de dólares que espera
que los republicanos también lo apoyen
esto a pesar de que el futuro presidente
de la cámara de representantes haya
dicho en campaña que iba a cortar la
ayuda militar Ucrania si llegaba a ser
presidente de la cámara de
representantes como se espera ocurra el
tres de enero del próximo año
[Música]